as a parent you were like whatever she's
who she is and I don't need to ask her
no she didn't she didn't volunteer no
information I didn't ask no Howard issue
okay she's the only one in my house one
trying to get no dick
everybody else was trying to get dick
they was claiming not the one dollar on
top of the roof going down the street
sucking dick she's the only one at the
house reading gay books
[Laughter]
comfortable place a place for her to
come out and talk to you about it or
were you well she didn't never come out
and talk she just you know she went to
college and ran off and then I was like
hey are you gay she's like yes I said
come on home you can eat [__] in
Atlanta that's a whole bunch of [__]
that you can eat
and I love it is dead I didn't give a
[__] I don't eat [__] I don't want her
to tell me not to eat Chick-fil-A